there's so many different healing  modalities available how do you know  what's for you  it's so overwhelming yeah that is not  the way the way is to understand how  your body becomes an instrument of your  own decision making  and you will feel what a yes feels like  in your body what a no feels like and  this yes no  in your body becomes available to you  when you start to  foreground your self-care you know when  i was in medical school i was taught  that  nothing in your environment matters that  you're drinking or eating or thinking  you know or your partnership not it  doesn't matter so to learn that not only  do these things  matter but they are the only way to  actually resolve chronic illness which  conventional medicine has never  purported to do for one patient ever so  in order to access this concept of  working with the body  to come into greater alignment you must  look at all of these  choices and you must start to  decondition that brainwashing